[Applause]
well I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to I don't
know about you but growing up opening
credits were both the worst and the
coolest part of the movie you know how
before a movie starts you see trailers
for other films they're supposed to get
you hyped up and excited for what you're
about to see in the future
in some situations that's what the
opening credits were they were short
hype vehicles to get you excited for
what you were going to see some were
short somewhere long but most of the
time they were a good indicator of what
you were about to experience but
recently opening credits have become
kind of a dying art most films nowadays
only show the title he'll sometimes not
even that just throwing you into the
movie without any excitement or build-up
of what you're about to see I remember
getting the chills watching the opening
of Batman with that awesome Danny Elfman
music
I still marvel at the artistry and
imagination of the James Bond openings
heck they would parody them in other
movies and shows they were so well known
but in recent years movies had been
doing this less and less still resulting
in strong openings but no real
introductions which got me asking me
unfortunate question do opening credits
suck now
well first off it's important to know
that films haven't always been this way
in the beginning credits were given very
little attention only listing the title
and main actors and a couple people who
made it at first there were not a big
deal but as movies became more and more
popular it made sense to give more and
more people credit which made them a lot
longer remember in the old days end
credits were only saying the end on a
title card also the important stuff was
shown in the opening similar to a
program that give you in a play which is
kind of what films were seen as for
awhile
cinematic plays so much so that some
movies even had overtures before the
movie started a better time to give
credit than over the music from the
awesomeness you're about to see so soon
the overture was combined with the
opening credits give you excited not
only for the music you're about to hear
but the hard work all these people put
in to tell you an epic story but turning
the page is literally like a program was
starting to become a little dry so
filmmakers start to add a little bit
more excitement suddenly there were
pictures animations hints of what you
were about to see after a while the
opening credits were becoming an art
unto themselves in fact there are even
people who made a living creating
opening titles probably the best-known
is Sal best the genius behind it's a man
mmmm at world's Bartok is and several
Hitchcockian Scorsese films how don't
get me wrong some film still had little
to no opening credits at the time or if
they did they didn't always utilize the
artistry of them films like Breakfast
Club just show their credits against a
black backdrop how's that supposed to
get you excited some films would do half
and half as much as I make fun of Batman
and Robin it is still usually
interesting super ridiculous to say the
least but still visually interesting now
the opening titles do a good job getting
you hyped up the music the visuals the
sound effects it's practically not half
bad but then after the title appears
there shoehorned into the corner and all
while people are saying dialog related
to the story
it's super distracting but at least we
did have little bit of a cool titles so
you see well not every movie used
credits as an artistic hype train many
of them did but then things started to
change when a little movie called Lion
King game out it had one of the most
amazing openings of all time singing
about the circle of life and displaying
its title with a thunderous boom and
fitting with the film's theme the movie
also ended with the title and a
thunderous boom cleverly matching the
idea of the circle Sayle though other
films said hey we want to seem that
important so whether I match the movie
style or not
filmmakers started putting the title at
the end because we're so damn big and
epic we don't have time for opening
credits we just want to throw you in
there yeah that's awesome because of
this credit intros became less and less
showing only the title in the opening or
even saving that for the end obviously
trying to give the audience a point to
applaud because think about if you
applaud it at the end that must've meant
you had a good time right pay us money
to come back and see it again this led
more and more to opening credits
becoming extinct seemingly no more while
epic themes play immediately connected
to the film's identity no more will
clever visuals excite you with what
you're about to see without giving too
much away now it's just the title and
the film starts destroying so much of
the movies build-up however there is a
different alternative that's been
popping up many movies are now doing the
big epic credit sequences at the end of
the film movies like The Incredibles 300
and several of the Marvel films but a
surprisingly large amount of effort into
making the last thing you see energized
and impressive some respect this does
kind of make sense
I mean why split up the credits into two
and you can lump them all together
people also don't have to wait for the
movie to start and you don't have to
worry about spoilers you've already seen
it nothing's gonna be given away it's
kind of like a best-of reel like
remember in the 80s how they would show
you stills from the movie you just saw
trying to remind you of the good times
you literally just witnessed this is
kind of the same thing yeah remember -
running on water remember violets
stopping the bullets it was cool this
was a fun movie even bad films like mom
III can almost have you
back with fondness yeah those yetis
coming down the mountain were badass
wait no they weren't that sucked but you
almost got me their movie good for you
on top of that some films nowadays have
extra endings with the credits in fact
both Marvel and DC usually throw into
one at the end and one halfway through
so people aren't always walking out
during the credits
sometimes they're staying while great
artistry is being displayed so maybe
this makes a little bit more sense why
not go out on a high note after your
movie is over doesn't it add up more to
convince them at the end what a good
movie this is as opposed to the opening
there's pros and cons to this the
biggest one being people do leave Franco
Zeffirelli found this out in 1968 with
Romeo and Juliet during the end credits
he chose to have the family seemingly
reconcile while going into the church
that's a huge plot point but not only
are people exiting the theater by this
point but the credits are blocking half
their reactions a lot of animes do this
to movies like only yesterday in
Arrietty still keep the story going even
after the end credits are rolling what
an odd choice people think the film is
over and they're gonna miss what
actually happens at the end on top of
that having cool stuff during the
credits at the beginning of the film
just enhances the rewatch ability every
time Bedknobs and Broomsticks starts up
I get excited yeah look at all that cool
stuff I'm about to see again listen to
all that amazing music
which is battling Nazis hell yeah
imagine if Superman opened the same way
as Man of Steel no titles no credits
just starting how does that get you
hyped up it's nothing the Superman movie
on the other hand look at this the
credits are whizzing by you're traveling
through space the music is practically
singing his name
[Applause]
this is the opening Superman deserves
the title sequences can even lead to
great scenes and bad movies I like a lot
of people wasn't a fan of Mars Attacks
but holy smokes the introductions
amazing all the spaceships surrounding
the earth with both the goofiest and
most threatening March playing over I
went out and bought the soundtrack to
this movie again the soundtrack to a
film I didn't like but I would have even
noticed the music if it wasn't for this
introduction Lord a war got mixed
reviews but everyone agrees the opening
is phenomenal
following a bullet from its construction
to being shot is profoundly disturbing a
part of the movie some filmmakers are
trying to skip can actually be the best
part of the movie and it never would
have happened if you just want to start
the flick with no credits here's the
thing you know how a lot of people say
the film isn't as good as the trailer
well this is your chance to have the
trailer inside the film they get you
pumped up excited and give an
imaginative take on the movie that often
wouldn't be allowed anywhere else in the
film there's no scenes in James Bond
that would call for trippy models flying
through the air or shooting guns out of
their mouths but imagery like this is
now ingrained with bonds identity as
well as that famously stylized scene of
him turning and shooting these are so
famous they're used to help create other
film's identities and none of that would
have existed if we just said can't we
just start the movie opening powerhouses
like 2001 the good the bad and the ugly
and vertigo will lose a huge part of
their identity if this mindset kept
going but the good news is it's not
entirely extinct yet in fact comic book
movies the genre you could argue is
moving cool title sequences to the end I
also still have some memorable ones
today Watchmen is beautifully dark and
poetic guardians of the galaxy is
perfectly strange and bizarre and
Deadpool might take the cake for the
most hilarious opening title sequence in
years
both satirizing and paying homage to its
artistic importance I guess what I'm
trying to say is not every movie has to
have amazing opening credit
but we deserve in the variety that many
of them can still exist granted there's
great ending title sequences and there's
dull opening title sequences but the
idea that opening credits should be
gotten rid of because they take too much
time away is missing a huge part of the
film's identity
can you imagine James Bond Batman or
Deadpool without their opening credits
they're an important piece of the impact
a movie can have on you and phasing them
out to save time can steal away some
really amazing filmmaking so the next
time you watch an opening credits
sequence wondering when the movies going
to start considering the possibility
that it already has opening titles are
amazing if done right and can continue
to be so if we see their importance
we're not at the point yet we're opening
credits necessarily suck as there's
still a few out there who know how to
start a show but at the same time we
shouldn't encourage ourselves to get to
that point either if leaving a first
impression is as important as they say
then this is a concept that should
definitely keep going strong
not on the stylish credit guy remember
it so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out usually at this point
I cut to a video giving you an idea what
this charity is about but this time we
really don't need video because you have
already seen plenty of video if you
watch the news at all and this is the
Houston flood relief fund if you've been
keeping up you know the awful things are
happening in Houston right now and there
are still so many people that need help
this is a really good organization
they've already raised a fair amount of
money but really there are so many
people still in need and still homeless
and just needs so much help so even if
you've already donated to Red Cross or
another charity please consider giving
to this one too I know so many good
people in Houston and man they don't
deserve this so please definitely click
on the link see if even the tiniest bit
you can give a little bit more because
it's if you've seen any videos any
photographs you know what an awful time
they're going through so please
definitely click on the link and open up
your heart and give these people
something to hope for because they
really don't deserve this thanks again
you